envie de vie envie de vie je répète les
mots c'est un défi aux professionnels
une déformation professionnelle j'ai
commencé ma carrière comme metteur en
scène de théâtre et d'opéra et un
metteur en scène de théâtre il passe son
temps à chercher des images derrière les
mots un metteur en scène d'opéra il
passe son temps à chercher les images
derrière la musique par exemple c'est la
flûte enchantée
mais qu'est-ce qu'on quelle image on va
mettre derrière
quelle image nous suggère cette musique
et envie de vie pour moi c'est l'image
du mouvement la vie en mouvement l'envi
donne le mouvement à la vie et c'est
même plus précis c'est un traîneau sur
la neige une grande étendue de neige et
les draps les chiens file file bon train
la nuit est en train de tomber au loin
une maison avec des lumières
il va falloir va falloir choisir le
chemin on peut passer par la forêt il ya
peut-être des congères
on peut passer par la rivière on n'est
pas sûr que la neige soit épaisse il va
falloir faire des choix
les choix c'est finalement ce qui va
nous ce qui va nous fabriquer ce qui va
fabriquer notre vie mais nous fabriquer
également tout au long de la vie mais
étudiant à la sorbonne au 24 ans ils
sont en master le premier jour après
après la présentation je leur demande ce
qu'ils veulent faire la moitié n'en
savait rien l'autre moitié veut
travailler dans un milieu le milieu du
cinéma
le milieu de la télé le milieu de la
littérature de la musique ou de
l'informatique
je le redis c'est formidable c'est
formidable parce qu'en fait on peut
faire ce qu'on veut vous faire ce qu'on
veut dans la vie
alors évidemment dans la salle il ya un
peu de droit ils disent ah bon vous
croyez pas ce qu'on nous a dit que la
filière était bouché
le bac on avait passé c'était pas le bon
que l'école supérieure était pas si
supérieur enfin il ya des tas de verdi
mais bien sûr on peut faire ce qu'on
veut à condition qu'on sache ce que l'on
veut et l'envi c'est tout simplement ce
que l'on veut faire à mes enfants je
leur ai fait un cadeau quand il était
jeune je leur ai donné je leur ai offert
cette phrase de oscar wilde il faut
avoir des rêves très grand pour ne pas
les perdre de vue quand on les poursuit
et mon dernier fils m'a dit mais oui
papa qu'est ce qui se passe s'il ya du
brouillard
je lui dis s'il ya du brouillard tu
prends ta de sol tu dis tu prends pas du
tout seul tu prends ta boussole celle
qui va te donner ton or à toi et c'est
tout seul elle marche à l'intuition
alors la puissance ça fait un peu
ringard quand on parle de la puissions
au siècle de l'algorithme parce que
l'algorithme qu'est ce que c'est c'est
précisément une construction pour
empêcher pour bannir l'inattendu
l'inconnu le désordre alors que
l'intuition c'est ce qui va fabriquer de
l'inattendu fabriquer de l'improbable et
fabriquer du désordre et le désordre est
absolument indispensable à la création
et c'est même un des moteurs de
l'innovation
tout simplement je suis de cambrai les
bêtises de cambrai vous connaissez et
bien c'est l'histoire évident comme son
nom l'indiqué c'est une bêtise
1 c'était un bon gros sucre et un
apprenti a renversé deux dans une fiole
de menthe
bon après c'est de fait enguirlander
l'on goûté ils ont trouvé ça formidable
et maintenant les bêtises de cambrai son
timbre on est les bonbons qui se vendent
dans le monde entier on dit que c'est la
même chose pour la tarte tatin
mais dans notre métier c'est pareil dans
notre métier si vous voulez on essaie on
est on est comme tout le monde
les tenants de l'ordre parce que ça nous
rassure mais en réalité on se trouve
régulièrement bouleversé par le désordre
quand on a créé fort boyard dont le
premier numéro
c'était formidable il y avait le fort il
y avait des candidats il y avait des
hélicoptères il y avait des images
partout et surtout les candidats on les
avait piscione ils étaient maquillés
c'était bien et il y avait des ralentis
y avait de la musique est un peu comme
dans la publicité de pdg pedigree pâle
fou comme ça c'était formidable mais
c'était nul
ces terres qui avait aucune émotion on
n'y croyait pas c'était faux alors que
c'était vrai et le producteur jacques
antoine dit écoute c simple on enlève la
musique on enlève les ralentis et on
remet les forts et ça a été formidable
ça existe toujours et s'est vendu dans
32 pays
quand j'ai produit une chance de trop en
anglais nothing chance
ceux qui connaissent le livre le héros
principal c'est un homme principal c'est
tout le livre c'est un homme et c'est
interprété par alexandra lamy
il ya quand même fallu pas mal
d'intuition d'abord pour penser qu'il
fallait il mettre une femme
et puis pour convaincre et ça a été
extrêmement facile pour convaincre
harlan coben qui a quand même vendu deux
millions cinq avec un homme que l'on
allait faire une femme et le succès
était au rendez vous puisque c'était le
plus gros succès de tf1 des dix
dernières années et on a même on a même
réussi à vendre le conte le remake c'est
à dire le remake de l'adaptation avec
une femme aux états unis qui avaient
déjà les droits du livre et il y aurait
plein d'exemples comme ça où on fait des
changements quand j'ai monté la jeune
fille violaine de paul claudel
si vous voulez ça s'est passé à peu près
de la même façon mais les américains
sont pas les américains c'est pareil à
je veux dire il y avait une doxa qui
disait qu'il fallait pas mettre de
chansons dans une
dans un était sûr de faire un flop
heureusement cameron les a pas écoutés
quand il a fait le titanic mon avis dit
également qu'il ne fallait absolument
pas mettre de voix off
heureusement que les équipes de forrest
gump ils ont pas écoutés et pour ceux
qui aiment le cinéma le cinéma peut-être
plus anciens il y avait en n1
réalisateur formidable s'appelait roger
vadim qui a fait et dieu créa la femme
barbarella et ses films était un peu
foutraque pour reconnaître que c'était
un petit peu approximatif et il m'a dit
un jour écoute mes films
en fait sont froissés mais avec élégance
comme la com doit d'être un costume
d'été en lin en fait là que l'intuition
faut quand même faire attention parce
que c'est pas c'est pas si évident que
ça l'a créé 28 sion elle vient pas de
taper à la porte en disant oui tu dois
mettre une femme à la place d'un homme
non c'est un souffle
c'est quelque chose qui est murmuré il
faut vraiment écouté il faut tendre
l'oreille comme il faut tendre les yeux
pour voir les rêves et en fait cette
intuition si vous voulez c'est ce qui va
me donner confiance en moi et
l'intuition je pense que c'est comme une
langue étrangère plus vous la part les
taux et plus vous la pratiquez pour vous
la plus vous leur parlerez couramment
est en fait la confiance que j'ai en moi
elle va me servir d'une dinde a comme
ressort pour donner de la confiance aux
autres faire confiance aux autres alors
là aussi parlé de confiance c'est un peu
ringard
ça fait même le monde de oui oui un
puisqu'on nous dit partout que on est
même des hommes d'état qui dit si je
fais pas tout rien n'avance
1 et on nous interdit dans ce monde
d'infantilisation général on nous
interdit tout et son contraire et est
donc faire confiance à paraît un peu
incongru et pourtant personnellement
dans les affaires dans tous les domaines
dans lesquels j'ai travaillé j'ai pensé
que c'était même pas un choix c'est pas
une option c'est une évidence
on peut pas faire autrement faire
autrement me semble-t-il est une haie et
est bête et même dans les affaires c'est
une erreur si jamais le chien je leur
fais confiance
il court pour l'instant dans la nuit si
je leur fais pas confiance
qu'est ce qui va se passer ils vont
commencer certains vont s'arrêter vont
commencer à se mordre et de toute façon
ils vont s'arrêter et j'ai comme seule
solution de me mettre le harnais de
tirer le traîneau
donc j'ai intérêt à
faire confiance j'ai pas le choix quand
on a fait le château des oliviers dont
kate infections important c'est une
commande que j'étais directeur de
l'antenne de l epa france 2 c'est une
commande que j'ai passé en juin il
fallait livrer ce feuilleton parce que
c'était un feuilleton des têtes au corps
principe en était fan elle livré en
juillet toute façon on n'avait pas le
choix on ne s'était pas la peine
d'essayer de contrôler et de vérifier je
les confie un des plus grands
producteurs de la td qui s'appelle
pierre grimblat qui est décédé il ya peu
de temps qui était le papa de navarro le
papa des bastides que j'ai fait avec lui
et je lui dis coups de pierres je vais
te dire une formule que j'ai attribué à
lao tseu mais en fait elle était noir
ont fait on n'en prend pas plus de
risque à faire confiance aux autres qu'à
se faire confiance à soi même et je le
crois profondément dans notre métier
nous c'est un métier de confiance pour
ceux qui connaissent un peu ce type
d'affaires un film ça prend six mois ça
peut aller jusqu'à 10 millions dont
quand simon va dépenser cet argent
beaucoup de gens de toute façon si on
fait pas confiance on est dans le mur
donc ça sert à rien et la confiance
qu'on fait aux autres ils volent la
rende au centuple
ils se sentent les obliger cette
confiance pas désobliger ne sont pas les
obliger vis-à-vis de moi mais des
obligés de cette confiance ils vont
avoir envie de se dépasser et grâce à ça
on va pouvoir déclencher le le dernier
étage de 2,2 de cette fusée de la
confiance et la confiance que les autres
vont nous faire nous avons nous la
chance d'avoir un métier est fait
entièrement d'intermittent il ya deux
permanents dans ma société qui fait un
très gros chiffre d'affaires mais on n'a
pas besoin qu'on a on n'a que des
intermittents donc les intermittents ils
ont la liberté de travailler chez un
autre producteur de faire autre chose et
l'intermittent ça démarre au machiniste
les couturiers les maquilleurs enfin
tout le personnel et bien sûr les
acteurs et bien sûr les réalisateurs et
bien sûr les auteurs il faut il faut
qu'on les séduisent
donc il faut qu'ils aient confiance en
nous donc le la démarche est simple j'ai
confiance en moi je fais confiance aux
autres et des autres me font confiance
alors comment les autres nous font
confiance
les grands acteurs nous font confiance
pourquoi parce qu il semble qu'on ne va
pas les trahir sans qu'on va pas les
traiter parce que l'acteur il s'expose
son son sens profond de commerce c'est
lui donc on va bien le film et qu'on va
être attentif
à skis à tous qui tous qu'il est le
réalisateur pareil si jamais il loupe ce
film là en tant qu'intermittent ans il
retrouve à plus de travail et c'est pas
nous qui pourront lui en donner parce
que nous même si on a loupé le film
toute façon on n'aura plus de commandes
quant à l'auteur c'est pareil il veut
pas que son livre ça trahit veux pas que
ce mauvais film fait qu'ils ne vendent
plus de livres on sait on s'attaque
quand même à des très très bon vendeur
de livres c'est à dire harlan coben ses
80 millions de livres donc c'est pas
quelqu'un à qui on dit bah c'est pas
grave on vendra moins pareil douglas
kennedy
donc il faut qu'ils sentent dans notre
passion sans dans la façon dont on
travaille que le col qu'on est convaincu
pour pendant la neuvaine quand on est
allé le voir il avait beaucoup de livres
libres lui voulait faire d'autres livres
nous c'est celui-là qu'on voulait faire
donc il a fallu tenir dans lundi non
nous c'est ça c'est cette détermination
le fait que c'était celui-là on dit mais
tous les autres on les a tous lu non
c'est celui là qu'on veut pour telle
raison
et bien c'est ça qui l'a convaincu
d'être avec nous il est maintenant bien
sûr il est convaincu de revenir mais
parce que la confiance est très
important c'est un tissage évidemment
satis agen maillage les techniciens qui
nous reviennent on est content l'autre
jour j'ai vu un garçon il m'a annoncé
que son il avait rencontré sa femme sur
un tournage lui l'a longtemps et
maintenant il a un petit garçon de 7 ans
avait donc jeudi savait donc huit ans
qu'on se connaît
ça veut dire plus 80 ans de
compagnonnage à travers l'intermittence
et une dernière anecdote concernant la
confiance qu'on nous fait j'ai produit
un film s'appelait là le prix de
l'honneur avec michel sardou et une
quand il est arrivé le premier jour du
tournage il m'a dit écoute petit à
l'époque j'étais plus jeune il m'a dit
écoute petit j'espère que c'est bien
parce que je n'ai pas dû mais mon agent
m'a dit qu on pouvait le faire confiance
mais j'entends de la musique on est
arrivé donc la maison effectivement il
ya une fête dans cette maison il ya la
neige on arrête le traîneau on enlève
les chiens ils peuvent et on l'est
on les récompense parce que on a
continué ils nous ont bien amené et puis
le
le personnes donc rentrer dans la maison
et ses amis l'attendent et lui dise ça
s'est bien passé
il dit oui ça s'est très bien passé
parce que j'étais certain de vous
retrouver
[Applaudissements]